with almost 500 sessions at next 2019
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
best practices GCP resource organization
and access management then stay tuned
because here's the rewind regardless if
you're new to Google cloud platform or a
longtime user it's important to keep all
your GCP resources organized we don't
just mean resources like VMs but
actually at the project and organization
level in this talk max and Greg go over
what these different resources are and
best practices for organizing them it's
important to consider the setup since
almost a third of billing support cases
that we handle end up being resource
management related if you're not sure
how your resources are configured you
may find yourself dealing with confusing
invoices access issues or even potential
disruption of service the best way to
avoid these issues is to make sure
everything is set up to match your needs
let's take a look at the resource
hierarchy here's an overview of the
different resources will step into each
area and talk about different things to
consider your domain and organization
are like an umbrella for everything in
the cloud the domain is done through G
suite or cloud identity and helps you
manage users organizations let you
manage all the GCP resources through the
console together these make sure you
have a way to manage everything from a
high level especially helpful for
situations when someone may have lost
access to a low level resource like a
project you'll have a super admin for
the domain and an organizational admin
for your organization which could be the
same person make sure to consider who
should be the admin in each case such as
the orga demin being a more senior
technical member in charge of all the
cloud projects it's also key to make
sure everyone knows who the admins for
these are and to keep all the roles up
to date try to aim for a reasonable
level of redundancy to avoid any single
points of failure bailing accounts are
under the organization and control how
you pay for anything the associated
projects use they have their own set of
roles and permissions such as the
billing account users who can see how
much each project is spending and Link
projects to a billing account only a
billing account admin can remove
projects from the billing account and
set budgets again it's important to know
who your billing admin is because
they're needed if you ever want to
contact billing support in most cases
you'll only need one billing account per
organization which will also help keep
things simple when looking at what
you're paying per project don't forget
to enable
big query export as soon as possible so
you can further analyze what you're
paying for now the payments profile
actually sits outside the cloud and is
used for paying anything in Google such
as chrome licenses you may want to have
the same admin for both your payments
profile and your billing account but you
can customize who has access to edit
information or only have read-only
access just like your billing account we
typically recommend only having one
payment profile making sure the right
people have access and getting
notifications can go a long way and
avoiding any fire drills you should also
add a secondary payment method and
review the rules here on a regular basis
to avoid any potential problems anything
done on GCP will be done from a project
which are basically like groupings of
direct cloud resources such as
kubernetes clusters these projects can
exist under folders as well as be
labeled so you have full customization
over your hierarchy in fact we recommend
trying to match your company's
environment so maybe you'd have a folder
for each team or different folders for
dev and prod you should use naming
conventions that are familiar to your
team for projects and labels so everyone
knows what each project is for labels
can help group those together each
project also has its own role management
so you can ensure only trusted people
can edit resources inside of a project
or even create new projects this is a
quick overview of the resource hierarchy
but there's plenty more specifics and
best practices to check out which you
can read through in the guide and
checklist linked here max and Greg go
into a deeper dive for each area during
the talk cover more best practices and
walk through an example of what a
company might consider for the resources
as they grow if you'd like to see the
full talk check out the link in the
description below and don't forget to
subscribe to the cloud YouTube channel
for more great next rewind content
thanks for watching
[Music]